you
good morning good afternoon good evening
everyone welcome back to day five of
GameSpot's best of 2017 coverage it is
Friday December 16th 1515 dad's birthday
nice happy birthday Bruce Brown yes
that's Peter Brown I'm Mike McCarty here
with KY Aggie
Jake Decker how's it going so Monday was
near automata that was number ten number
nine what remains a via Finch hell-blade
sending a sacrifice Wolfenstein to the
new Colossus and today we are about to
get into a video that Jake cut for our
number six game really quick just to
reiterate next week because the weekend
will be taking off from these streams
starting Monday we'll announce our
number 5 game Tuesday will be number 4
and then Wednesday December 20th at 10
a.m. Pacific will have this mega stream
where we go straight through three to
one and do the same thing discussions on
them and then like gameplay sessions
with a live stream but without further
ado here is number six on GameSpot's
best of 2017 list
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
strengths to stand alone alloy is the
strength to make a stand to serve a
purpose greater than yourself
that is the lesson you must learn
[Music]
[Music]
there have it horizon zero dawn from
guerilla games over in Amsterdam is our
number six game of the year
one of the more fantastic open-world
games to come out pretty much ever this
came out right in February right before
breath of the wild and the switch hit so
it was unfortunate competition but it it
does so many things well on its own just
like apart from other games in general
that it was kind of hard to forget
Jake you played frozen wilds recently I
want to talk about because you played so
much that I want to talk about the world
and like what makes this world so
memorable it's such a cool setting like
what post post apocalypse they were
calling it yeah it's yeah post post
apocalypse like the machines sort of
have taken over and pushed the humans
back essentially and they're fighting
back yeah I was like how many threes ago
two or three when they first showed this
game off sure yeah and I was like eh
like crouching in tall weeds and she was
hunting for their what gun that she
likes she hacked a longneck and then
just like yeah she like put a tripwire
tripped while it fell over she took a
gun off of it was using that it's not a
unique setting I would say it's like I
do want to talk about the story itself
with a LOI obviously it's kind of like
two-tiered almost there's the tribal
stuff that has arisen out of the post
post apocalypse but then there's also
figuring out what led to all this cuz
like I mean it's it's not a spoiler this
is earth but its live talk about that
but between the tribal stuff and the
post apocalypse stuff Pete you reviewed
this game liked it a lot give it a 9
back in the day yeah
February and you liked it a lot but I
want to talk about that kind of a duel
setting whether they work well together
yeah I mean like early on in the game
you are playing as a boy and obviously
and you find you stumble into you you
know you sort of like fall into like
down a hole into this space that's like
very futuristic and you uncover this
little device that gives her the ability
to sort of like see it like behind the
curtains of reality in a way or like
communicate with with people that maybe
the tribe isn't really aware of it's
like a really advanced Bluetooth focus
piece of focus yeah is what it's called
and that is you the
you sort of gain his connection to the
story behind everything else and it
becomes very sci-fi along with this
tribal thing and the tribal stuff works
in terms of establishing her character
it the game leans on it a lot but when
it's at its best is when it really leans
into sci-fi stuff because the world
itself is so captivating and so
mysterious in terms of like well how did
the machines get to this point without
anyone you know intervening behind the
scenes and was there someone
interviewing behind the scenes and those
those questions slowly grow more complex
and the answer is grow more interesting
it really just builds in the world
supports a lot of that Kelly you have a
long history with shooters it was it
weird seeing guerrilla games the
creators of Killzone one through three
and Shadowfall and the spin-off game
going to this absolutely I to be honest
I wasn't expecting the combat to be so
good I mean this is some of my favorite
combat at the whole year and I I mean
Peter was talking about it earlier today
about how like not having high hopes
because you're kind of thinking like a
Killzone I've been a little disappointed
by this and then they just like totally
change tactics and it really really
worked for them and I think that like
the the futuristic technology you know
that's probably the most like Killzone
ish yes everything else is like
completely surprising combat a
surprising story and I was so pleasantly
surprised so we're watching it right now
tell me about the combat what is it that
makes it so fun and so challenging I
really like that you're fighting these
mechanical beasts and each one is
different and and I hesitate to say
unique but there's different ways to
approach all these different beasts and
like I love in games the feeling of
being overpowered because it's so much
more satisfying to me to overcome that
and that's one of the most like one of
those satisfying things about about the
game is is figuring out how to to take
down a machine with a bow and arrow and
you can get really creative with it and
I just really enjoyed the the
flexibility and how I was constantly
re-evaluating my strategies yeah as I
went through the game yeah Jake we like
early in the game you can kind of I mean
I was talking about how I thought I
could just spam tear arrows for a while
the ones that
have that little mini like implosion
yeah that pulls off the armor of the
armor or specific weapons of the robots
which are all kind of modeled after real
dinosaurs or animals around like their
crocodiles the ice ma zouri much
crocodiles alligators but later on you
have to start like rearranging your
tactics right you have to say okay I
know this kind of animal is gonna attack
me this with this element so I'm gonna
try to put this tripwire down that's its
weakness and lure it in and then when
it's sundial hit it with a spear and
then I'll back out and then hit that
bird of the terror arrow do you feel
that like over the course of the game
that combat became more and more nuanced
as you fought new animals and went on
through the world yeah definitely I mean
in it it almost the beginnings like
nothing it starts out slow but like
you're very reliant on your bow yeah and
that kind of seems like your main way
but as you get further along you start
you start juggling a bunch of different
weapons to take down enemies and it's
it's pretty exhilarating especially like
how well the controls are like it's easy
to flip between them it's easy to craft
new craft ammo like it's it's just very
fast-paced like it's not like you're
gonna rest at a campfire and like make
some arrows you're just going constantly
yeah crafting on the fly is another
thing that makes it so like you said
exhilarating to to be in these fights
it's a very intricate process then the
game does a really good job of like
leading you into like it teaches you how
to do these things one by one and it's
surprising like how well it all fits
together because on paper a lot of
complex things are happening yeah very
short amount of time it's less like it's
less like oh I got a level up I gotta I
gotta become more powerful to take this
thing down it's more about all right
well what weapon do I need to take this
down where should I shoot it
what kind of positioning should I have
yeah sometimes you don't even know where
their weak points are you have to take
their armor off yeah to find those and
even that like surviving while trying to
do that because you're not really
damaging them just by taking their armor
off too much just a this game does get
pretty tough later on especially like in
the latter stages of the story mm-hmm
when you're fighting someone like the
t-rex ish yeah oh the invisible Jaguars
are the things that kind of be like
you're still walking through a fortune
like I just see the light shift a little
bit and before you know it there's like
things flanking you on both sides that
you see for half a second and it's just
like Oh
[ __ ] like how do I deal with that and
then that goes back to the taxes you
were mentioning of luring them into like
trip wires and other booby traps what
about that comes really important sorry
what about the technical achievements of
this game you're really you were talking
about how like impressive it isn't like
how ya little credit they get for
building certain things from the ground
up I think if you if you look at like
what they've achieved with staring at
the screen because it's up there but if
you look at what they've done with the
world itself like it is very like
realistic in a lot of ways and you are
given like incredible like draw draw
distances here to see this stuff and
even on a regular PlayStation 4 all of
that looks fantastic like I think it
rivals some of the best games on PC that
require like high-end graphics cards and
it seems to be that they just they've
really optimized their engine and pull
off some really great stuff and that's
you know the frozen wild is not part of
the reason why this game is where it is
on our top of the Year list but that if
you get to play that after the fact you
see even more technical achievements
that are just pretty astounding I mean
this is the you know these consoles now
are what almost 5 years old yeah and
they're still surprising us with stuff
ps4 word apparently this month just had
its best month ever
Cochise how it could be a beat its
previous record from like two years ago
or something thing but yeah then going
from the desert what is the city
Meridian mhm that's in the desert and
then you go south of that it's these
lush jungles where the rivers flowing
into Meridian and then you mentioned
like when you're walking through the
snow and the frozen wilds like up to
your shins and it actually feels like
it's high snow yeah like I someone who
grew up like with snow like you you're
very familiar with what it is so like
truck home from school like you know
that day that it wasn't canceled and
having to get through all that and it's
really arduous and like you kind of you
feel that and how guerilla games pulled
that off for the frozen wilds is it's
pretty fascinating and it's interesting
to see that they even put that work in
because the main game has snow but it
didn't have those features and they just
sort of went the extra mile so like it's
it's great to see that even throughout
the year it was supported in such a
great way I really liked that despite
the fact that some of the things word is
collectibles they kind of like a lot of
them were like startup mugs like from
yeah tech companies and stuff I actually
kind of liked that because yeah yeah I
really like the artifacts
yeah just reading like where the world
came from
shitty startup names and like yeah that
actually could exist yeah I'm like weird
like not emails but like kind of just
like you can read sort of like articles
in the seven yeah it really interesting
like office politics it's like you
believe like geo was being such an ass
today yeah did you guys find any of the
Kojima stuff in the game no really
there's Kojima stuff there's a series I
think of like 11 or 12 maybe less but
yeah like multiple things that seemingly
have stemmed from the deal that could
you miss struck with guerrilla games to
use their engine for death stranding
because this game came out like a few
months after the fact and there are
things that has their mascot on it like
for the icon right barton thing homo
Luden's
yeah yeah but like just like on so many
levels horizon zero dawn is such an
achievement for guerrilla games and just
for it it almost like you know like
breath of the wild obviously it's easy
to compare them because they came out so
close never both mmm so some of the few
open-world games that came out this year
compared to past years but like I think
horizon is the pinnacle of open-world
design as it's been building up over the
past like six years it definitely feels
that way yeah yeah I it's it's one of
those games where like an open-world you
want to be able just to exist in it
without having the objectives that are
fed to you and I feel like I can just go
anywhere in this game and have a great
time and be impressed with it as well
Kelly we're talking Wolfenstein 2
yesterday you're saying you like wolf
ins well I feel like Wolfenstein new
order and new Colossus because they kind
of allow you to go take a stealthy
approach or all-out combat this game
kind of lets you be stealthy obviously
with the spear yeah sneak attacks did
you try to do that as often you could in
this game anymore I love stuff yeah I I
did a lot of stuff in this game and I
mean there's I love the skill tree like
I'm a sucker for a good skill tree and I
like that you can eventually unlock
everything but like as you're you know
discovering the world and discovering
the game and learning you know you can
start with maybe your comfort zone so I
did start with a lot of stealth and then
I kind of branched out and I figured out
new ways to approach things that that
surprised me that I enjoyed so much
because I am such a you know
Prowler as
nice that's what that says right yes
yeah yeah I just like I like the
flexibility it affords one of the
coolest things about stealth is that you
can override the machines even like the
giant ones you sneak up behind it you
like stick your spear in it or whatever
yeah and then you can just watch these
huge battles play out between machines
you don't even do that you just sit back
and watch and it is it is really cool to
see some of those funny YouTube serious
or someone did that they were depending
animals and like commentating over it
you do the cauldrons to unlock the
ability to get like third tier animals
yeah and the cauldrons are I mean the
world is beautiful outside but the
cauldrons are beautiful from like this
alien technical level like it's just it
it's such a contrast to the world above
there was once I the first time I walked
into one of those it was just so yeah
breathtaking and that's the most
impressive thing for this game for me is
how fluidly it switches between like
hard sci-fi back to fantasy back to just
this open world kind of wilderness
adventure but then it you it just
doesn't stick to one constraint it's not
constrained by any of these they just
didn't complement each other in such a
fantastic way and it's almost like by
the time you figure out the backstory
and what happens it cause this
apocalypse like it actually I feel like
it earns its story which a lot of open
world games struggle to do they don't
know how to balance like side quests and
the main narrative I mean like fallout 3
is one of my favorite games by still
like I remember the side quest from it
but I'd remember the main narrative from
horizon zero dawn and it's fantastically
written and I think it's paced very well
when you're actually finding those
things out
absolutely but yeah that's pretty much
horizon zero dawn our number six game of
2017 from guerrilla games so
congratulations to the studio and
Amsterdam
winning a lot of awards deservedly as
we've been seeing we have been
announcing our top 10 games throughout
this week and like I said we're taking
this weekend off but we will be back
Monday at 10:00 a.m. Pacific to announce
our number 5 game we're getting into our
top 5 so horizon zero dawn closed out
the bottom 5 which doesn't really it's
not a blow to it because it was a
fantastic year to make our top 10 was
just an achievement in its own right but
please go get
caught up on all of our other best of
2017 games if you have time to play like
what remains of being Finch this weekend
or finish up horizon oh yeah or play
Wolfenstein - the new Colossus and catch
up before Monday when we announced our
number 5 game but if you're watching
this live and not on you super GameSpot
we are gonna be playing horizon zero
dawn for about half an hour Jake's gonna
take the controls right now if you want
to and we're gonna play through some of
it we're in the story would this be
alright we're in a game like how far
this is this is post game era post it's
like frozen yeah I figure we'll just go
around explore the world fight some cool
monsters because that is I mean you got
a bird and a crab right there
thanks mom what do that because there's
two different kinds of birds right
there's those are the scary birds the
storm birds are real scary you see one
like right when you start to up like
right when you get out of the first day
or used to the desert yeah it's like
that was that was a cool wake-up call
cuz I felt really confident up until
that point so these guys yeah I think
they oh this is just a regular snap mom
I don't think it's the elemental one
elemental ones will have a little
canister as you can blow up that like
freeze them this is a really good way to
okay three seconds thunder oh it's
underneath right it's going a word I
love it's a good word nice nice a gun
and yeah you also you know depending on
how you break this stuff off of them you
get specific resources that are harder
to get if you just kill the animal
outright and crafting is not just your
ammunition obviously but like your
various pouches or like carry more
things which I will say one of the one
of the weaker aspects of this game that
definitely is improvement is the
inventory management it's for the amount
of items you collect and for the number
of ways you can use them it's actually
too cumbersome I think but a lot of
games really struggle when they'd they
blow up like you know all these
different like categories and
ways to get resources and things that
certain resources apply to
yes I say as much as I I kind of joke
around saying that I could spam tear
arrows which optimator the game is not
true but I do like that they require
more resources and like they know how
valuable they are yeah especially oh my
god oh my god you can't use a shock
stuff on the birds can you it doesn't
really do anything to them isn't I like
their strengths oof
what I can do that I'm not positive I'll
stop ahead I also like the way you kind
of like build up health reserves by
gathering from the field yeah yeah it's
so easy to get comfortable swimming you
swim against the current in place this
is going well anyway I haven't died yet
health health management is good
I also love getting one of the shadow
cars opposed I think that had a pretty
good flame damage at Google kid it's
that you can use flame arrows with it
and then it had three slots and I just
put three legendary fire boat sometimes
you run into the gladiators oh yeah it
isn't just like one of the Bounty Hunter
groups here now I think you're in that
weird territory
where are you in the map like central
yeah do you have your like explosive
slingshot passing shots I have one it's
not very good gotta do one more you
civilities unlock was the long dodge
when you hold circle yeah there's a lot
of that because the dodge wouldn't
always work for a lot of the well some
of the ones that are kind of like Rams
they do one attack and they'll keep
going and if you don't dodge multiple
times a rail you just get screwed all
right it's not doing anything
you got to go for the the canisters on
its shoulder what arrow is that with in
a nuts and bolts or does this crap Rio
just gives you a high obvious how much I
believe I didn't know I want to find one
of these things entire health bar run up
off that uh back now crop it some
slow-mo combo on the shoulder
what game showed that first was it Zelda
or this the slim oboe I want to see
Zelda yeah I could be wrong a great
feature
much more in this it's a girl yeah I
can't not get out of it and not so you
do it yeah do you think it's super cool
trip casters no no no that's up get down
I turned off a lot of the HUD so I don't
know like Jesus oh my god get that
shoulder canister yeah uh prettier focus
is pretty helpful to know should I do
like it's gonna pair up there it's a
good illustration what we're talking
about this like [ __ ] some of the
fighter just like mini oh yeah yeah you
come across like a river and you're like
the liver River looks pretty nice that
could use a little drink in the water
oh [ __ ] and there's like this huge worm
that comes out of there so cool
there's yeah those are my favorite and
there's barf up like rocks at you yeah
the first thing you go isn't that key
that ravine or the quarry or whatever
where everybody's like yeah we don't
know something a tower to do look it's
not doing a lot but yeah like that
you're constantly like switching your
approach and like switching which
weapons you're using and and you have to
take a multi-pronged approach to this
machine which is really cool the burden
going down yeah that bird is there you
go
it's also like in addition to doing big
chunk bigger chunks of damage to them it
it takes away abilities to yeah we're
definitely changes some of the tactics
like if I come into ice my snap Maas
with a elementals that I'll just take
that
sacks out immediately so I can't okay
like yeah freeze you yeah oh my god
yeah chef you get like Peter was saying
you get like different resources and
like that is a factor too especially
like because you're crafting with I mean
if you haven't merchants require stuff
yeah like there's that element to the
strategy as well which i think is it's a
more subtle thing but really creative
whoa correct me if I'm wrong you can
overload your bows right
it's multiple arrows uh certain bows
right oh no no yeah you can't you press
a yeah there's an ability right triangle
while you're aiming I think it's are oh
that's sorry that's stop focus oh yeah
r1 sounds right you may have so you may
have not unlock that ability I should we
all believe in you there you go boy over
here there you go have fun with that now
that guy was like wait what are you
[Laughter]
we could do you wanna effort this is
over you want to show off the frozen
wilds or you want you can get in a bear
fight that'd be fun
robots are some reason to save doesn't
have my even have my frozen wild save so
I have to like go Tori's there's a
pretty tough boss fight eating you right
to make sure you're at the level that
yeah yeah no like it's yeah it's
gorgeous yeah I watch Pete and Jake and
someone else in the office boy yeah you
should try to find those crabs the crabs
that have the the big like shell that
you cannot go up and the field that they
kit right they have the shield and if
you knock the shell off you're gonna
like disables them but they can pick it
back up and put it back on their bond
right there oh you found if you guys
ever see that in a fight yeah yeah you
literally can knock it off and they'll
put it back on they were one of the
hardest enemies when I first discovered
them and you really have to study them
too
pardon me I think for me was definitely
the ones that drill underground but I
like found him pretty early on and I was
like I'm gonna kill these things and I
couldn't find one it was always two at a
time
hmm but I'll definitely try to find one
of those and those beetles too like the
oversized beetles that have those like
bodies filled with like whatever they
give a spring on you at any moment
and that that creeps me I don't like I
don't like bugs that are the wrong size
something like that it's not natural
actually I think the well will fight
these guys first but I think right up
there I can fight the tunnel thing is
the tunnel snake okay
total snakes rule the UK team convinced
me that there I hope they're not
watching enough to probably pick it up
did you give him a second you will when
I was in London they told me they were
they found out I don't like snakes and
they found they told me they were too
busy any time the yeah the underground
stopped in the middle of tunnels because
they were running over snakes yeah and
like it was weird enough and I it was my
first time in London that I knew it was
I kind of thought I knew as a joke we
need to get this mother effing the snake
out of this mother oh hi everyone's like
Americans
yeah Australia there's like the the
thing they tell foreign you know people
in other countries about drop bears oh
yeah what bears drop there's a kiss yeah
it's drop bears are these they look like
koalas but they're far more vicious and
violent and they essentially will drop
out of trees and maul you when you're
not paying attention they're also
completely made-up because literally
everything there will kill you yeah but
you see all these photos of like drop
airs and it's really just like a koala
that had like fallen into some mud and
then came out like happened to get like
in a territorial bout where you had to
like look angry for a second but yeah
it's like vicious like - he look
ambassadors and you're like oh my god
like they're real and then Australians
laugh at you like they do I mean it was
a koala when I went to
and they it was not happy to see me you
healthy koala I did not like it oh my
god oh my god yeah I mean where else are
the crabs gonna hang out though let's do
the beach get your minds out of the
gutter there kids watching I was gonna
just go back to water boy and say water
sucks it really really sucks
which is my theme song really shoot that
gun off his back use it against him yeah
I love picking up the weapons a drop
good searches my god like this huge
two-handed things use them enough at all
all they're fun yeah I like the ones
that fire like just discs just like
red-hot discs that just tear into
enemies what our crabs I'm so stressed
I'm back can't keep a crab down off so
it's slid backwards so if you meet it if
you yeah I think if you lure it back it
should pick it back up no come back for
you later like right like right now
open let misremember - thanks so if I go
up too far here I think I get attacked
by there do it go and just go all out
all right well you should really slow-mo
jump off and kill that the one shot that
little guy the cracker fun yeah he's
gone now there was one of the like you
know the two legged guys this is going
great
it was far better than I would be doing
if I play this game right now I know
Fame is one thing like I plan my classes
I played a lot of game back in like
February March and then jumping into it
two months ago you have to really react
Lemaitre yourself yeah I think there's
so much to learn there's so much going
on yeah and I hate to sit again but I
think we'd all just played so much of
breath of the wild after this and there
are just enough similarities that your
brains like kind of immediately last
other words I will say they're less
comparable then oh yeah then they're
very uncomfortable but yeah it's just
it's like you have that like sensibility
that yeah muscle memory that's hard to
shake I think Oh nah cuz it's not the
belly off those grazers well that's fun
I'm gonna it's like an override one
because cubes are pretty yeah yeah
do move inherits oh god don't her out
[Laughter]
are you gonna finish that oh my god wow
you have not died thought river like two
clicks back just the fact that you can
possibly kill these things is amazing to
me right like that you're given the
tools to do that there's a lone
individual yeah just a girl with a bow
and arrow in a sphere scheme becomes
like a boss rush for different kinds of
yeah your soul is mine yeah don't like
that scene from oh there we go
oh you can only do one I ride this thing
yeah sometimes you can only override and
have them fight it alongside of you
other ones like the jungles of South
America there yeah yeah the the shitty
like green stuff dawn or dusk like when
the Sun is like you know sort of just
coming over their eyes under the other
opposite dress looking at we're gonna go
to one of those beetle thingies
yeah I don't get some recall what your
juice they're the big kegs of the Civic
beer they're uh the first ones you meet
they have ice blowback I think is what I
saw
well Beck's can't remember and I think
it's it's it's fair to talk about the
fact that the ending pretty much hints
that there's more of this coming down
the line yeah and I think Sony would be
stupid to ignore what do they do after
that's like go somewhere else
skateboarding time travel back to the
future skateboarding horizon absolute
zero he's just having a tough time my
keys dammit
alright so we're right here talking to
Bill all the weights you tired
oh no I'm great I feeling I'm at the top
of my game right now I don't think
there's anything for it to fight so I'm
just gonna kill this poor creature
call it a poor creature now it's sad is
it yes
is it weird that's playing this game
watching it gets me even more excited
for a boss it's remake I know it's not
entirely weird yeah yes but like just go
sense that like all these fights are
they're not just like you look because
you do fight humans in this game not to
the game's detriment I do I know a lot
people it's not the high point but I do
think it's a nice change of pace when
you could just shoot something in the
face and it dies yeah but the base
infiltration stuff is weird it's not
always totally necessary yeah but you do
get the option to do that there's short
lived and they do they do get pretty
difficult where you can't just sort of
Barrel in yeah but like it's it's uh but
yeah I know what you mean right terms
like shadow Colossus it's not just like
hordes of enemies between you and the
next boss yeah much fighting mini bosses
a whole oh here they are
it's these guys do that the rock records
yeah can I want to see a t-rex as well
if we have time we will do that I'll
take care of these these guys so tight
could you just do that is it a t-rex you
fight to get into frozen wild or no no
no I think it's one of the Bears that
you fight isn't it yeah no no it's one
of those like Jaguar yeah the Bears are
a little bit later dude they're tough
they're really really tough cuz they're
sliding under their legs so cool so
they're really resistant to tear arrows
so you really can't rely too much on
those so just sort of like Whittle them
down and bring em myself
you said two terrier arrows I have a
scar on my arm from a terrier biting me
you can only see like yeah
a terrier was being chased by another
dog I picked up the terrier the other
dog came at me and instead of biting the
dog I was chasing it the terrier [ __ ]
me he was trying to save it
my dog is a terrier they're useful
ivanishin no just kidding yeah just
let's check out some of the other armor
because I feel like this armor sucks
thanks no just show the shadow car just
stuff like that like the really dope oh
you don't there you go that's pretty
that's not the one you get from the know
what is that called
I forget how do you even get it don't
know you have to get those uh there's
there are collectibles hidden in far
reaches of the world some you find
during story naturally yeah other ones
you really have to go out of your way to
find oh my god the armor doesn't work
out quite the way you expect based on
because the whole game you can see it
behind glass but when you get it it
doesn't actually look on you the way it
does behind glass right doesn't it not
show up on her head it doesn't really
show up on much of her body but you get
rather than the big suit is you get this
sort of like like fluorescent like
transparent armor that glistens around
you I think it was played a bit during
the montage
if you shoot off all it's like pause it
you can't dig and it just lays there
like a giant seal
yeah just flopping around the beach yeah
he's got some acid beer - yeah yeah oh
gosh they're like the yeah yeah make
another breath of the wild comparison
but it's like those what lewis is called
Oh in the desert well do go well do got
it yeah you gotta France with an
Australian accent there you go alright
well you just keep popping their head at
my dance the Viking bounce their soda
ball - good well Australian like where's
the car New Zealanders we're like
where's the car
I know Edmund Tran is ahead in his hand
just shaking it Wow that to go so much
help rockbreaker booty shaker we take
our job seriously we're we're all gonna
get fired at this yeah
it's like ma the the rock breakers mouth
it's almost like a creditor but it's all
like yeah it's um oh no I know you're
talking about or what well I mean it's
from Zelda as well this is Bob Ruda the
divine beast the chameleons face opens
up hmm
but I'm thinking Emma's gonna spread
interlocks are like Haley from halo Oh
you're frozen wild stuff all right let's
go see you t-rex you know what's weird
is every time you go kill take out a ban
of camp lift that character that helps
you the one the creepy one that's always
there and saying like killing bandits
makes me so oh right your your portly
chubby friend right he looks like an
Oscar and I think Kevin his name he's
always just hanging home buddy
all right t-rex hey yeah some I would
look for the one in like the grassy
valley so I just fought the one in the
desert so I'm comfortable fighting Alan
right the less water possible yeah the
Thunder jaws makes cursor just
gravitating toward the river's Templars
trample er what was that called uh what
yeah trample err yeah that makes more
sense
no I think if you go Templars Templars
Ubisoft get them get out of here cause
I'm safe I went in snow
now whatever just pick whatever one you
find first charcoal awesome all right
there yeah problem is there's no fast
travel location nearby well yeah that's
true but you could you don't have a like
the Summoner mounts ability I do yeah
yeah just don't you're buying something
about hightailed out of there the I
there's like a gift going around a
couple weeks ago of how cool or the cool
way that this game handles aiming and
360 degrees while riding amount oh yeah
yeah like naturally like shifts her legs
like over the the hump of the animal and
then like it's other back you know I
guess she's like just spinning around
like it's pretty it's next it's pretty
cool
it hasn't makes sense rather hurt just
turning 360 degrees that are better ways
he played pub G the animations of people
hanging out windows craziest muscles
yeah their cores are just like concrete
but yeah it's impressive in this game
he's made by naughty list
should we add his name I think we should
everyone looked at that right away I
forgot that was there but technically I
wrote that so that is my naughty list
[ __ ] cray Mass Effect Andromeda face a
switch voice chat RIT Vita is that
really like nany just died yes I think
it was Rob's jokes loot crate's was I
don't know okay so this is t-rex do you
yeah he's got a normally you probably
take the time to stop yeah I've got no
health so well at least no reserve
health I guess the solution can you do
that animation quick on yeah don't know
that I've seen is pretty it takes off
and you fall off why are you wearing
that armor again yeah why am I wearing
this on right again why argue and did
you die isn't that way so we jump I
don't really use a mouth on this game
that often why I'd also don't think I
got this summon mount ability that
definitely makes it a more useful yeah
too much until I got some amounts cuz it
was like travel to an area that had a
packet and hop on the game just feels so
good when she's running around like yeah
that's one thing I'll say I think it so
it has over breath of the wild its but
I'm more comfortable fast traveling in
breath of the wild in this game I feel
like I actually want to experience the
change because the environments they
changed more frequently and a lot of
them compared a lot of other open world
games and to see those transitions stay
over there knocking down trees yes the
wind farm in the background yeah you
know
of the past he's cool with those in the
wind so you definitely want to knock off
his guns and use those against him
oh my god let's get off this thing huh
[Laughter]
it's going great so far so yeah he's got
the two guns on the side nice good job
and then he's got the like satellite
launcher guys he's got one on each cheek
doesn't he oh yes on his cheek sorry
yeah he's got the guns on his cheek that
you can use he's got that satellite
launcher on the top of his back drone
sure yeah either one I don't know why
I'm saying sadly I'm gonna make sense
water rolling
some traders in his life
all right I think you should be able to
go get that one not gone near yeah what
was that
this is blinding you know what this
behind oh my god Roger one shot that
dude oh my gosh dang oh he's still alive
never he's in the crevice oh he's a
red-eye watcher that's why god dammit
he's in the crevice like 12 people got
to it only the sunniest that's became
the dis one it doesn't render a retching
Clank on but cooler if we had a better
audio so you can hear this
is a saw blade going through it or
something
see I guess it could be a saw
just kill this [ __ ] and then call it a
stream or a while or yeah one of us dies
yeah
yeah cage matches worse if they didn't
work everybody would still be in the
cage it should be shooting the heart
right now see it is that you can see the
heart on it it's like yeah it's kind of
like on its neck but you can only see it
from the side and it has this a little
chip thing on its head but super
satisfying to like leap off things and
oh God prove it
I don't know what I can leap off of I
guess I gonna rock this hill a little
bit Oh God
disgusting red thing yeah there we go
you try some in the mountain right now
like a [ __ ] that
you know shoot its booty canisters
though it's wrong folks turn silos pull
them out help me out here
god this develop a bit trying to eat
help this [ __ ] still sorry this guy
still just I'm getting so amped up
watching this fight don't you do it Jake
[Laughter]
right into the river
Jake gets mugged in San Francisco just
dives into the ocean alright you got
this guy yeah yeah yeah
don't try to melee it to death yeah
Layton I don't know where it is I'm very
much man well damnit death will desert
yeah alright sweet thanks Jake alright
and everybody if you're watching this
live thank you so much for joining again
go catch up on all our game of the year
stuff so far our best of 2017 I'll get
in trouble if I say Game of the Year I
guess I'm just kidding taste back there
shaking his head but now thank you so
much for joining taking the weekend off
like I said go catch up on some of these
games you haven't finished Wolfenstein -
or this or near automata if you haven't
played war means to be authentic and you
could take like two hours to play it do
that hell-blade same thing six hours or
so maybe a little more you play that
this weekend if you haven't played it
yet and then come Monday we'll announce
our number 5 game we're getting into the
really really good ones not to say
anything bad about the last 5 we've
announced because this game was this
year was fantastic for releases and
anything on top 10 list is quite an
achievement but thank you so much for
joining and like I said 10:00 a.m.
Pacific on Monday we'll be back with our
number 5 game thanks and we'll see
then
you